RADHANATH SWAMI:
[SINGING IN SANSKRIT]
It is truly an honor and
pleasure to be with all of you
here at the headquarters
of Google this afternoon.
Thank you for giving me
this opportunity to speak.
Throughout the world, your
company, Google-- and of course
you know better than
me-- is so highly
respected as being one of
the most pleasing places
to work in.
And how that's possible,
in this age where there's
so much conflict
and people always
trying to find something else,
is something very special.
And of course what you are
contributing to society
is literally affecting
practically every person
on earth's life.
So of course, along
with influence
comes great responsibility.
But I congratulate
you and your company
for what you are contributing.
Today's subject--
conflict resolution.
It can be approached from so
many different perspectives.
And if you're going to invite
a swami to Google, then
obviously, you're going to
hear a spiritual perspective.
It's one of the most difficult
things in this world today,
to cooperate.
What is the core reason why?
Why is there conflict
between family members?
Between people of The same
company, of the same nation?
Conflict between
different nations?
Conflicts with people within
the same religion, not
to speak of other religions?
Practically the news every
day, it's about conflict.
It's about me and you.
Or us and them.
And from a spiritual
perspective,
the core root of
that conflict is
conflict within our own
lives-- a disharmony
between the body and the mind.
A disharmony with
the mind with itself.
And ultimately a disconnection
between the body and mind,
the intelligence, and our true
self-- our hearts, our souls.
So much of what we do
is really disconnected
from our own hearts, what
to speak of our souls.
Because we're so allured
by external conceptions,
misconceptions, and
concerns that we
forgot the larger picture.
Or let us say the
higher principles
that really life is about.
I knew a man who I just
lived two blocks from when
I was a little boy, and
he was the wealthiest man
in our neighborhood.
And anyways, I kind of left
home when I was a teenager
and went to Europe, and
then hitchhiked to India,
and I never came back.
But I met somebody-- my old
friend Gary-- and he told me
what happened.
This person, before he died,
he gave his entire fortune
to his two sons and he
told them how to spend it.
One son bought a beautiful farm,
gigantic property in Oregon,
and got horses.
Pedigree horses.
He got an airplane.
He got a boat and
really nice cars,
and got married
and had children.
That was his father's
money, and he invested it
in ways that accrue.
The other son got involved
with people who influenced him
in a different way.
And they convinced him,
you can triple your money
if you just join us.
And he did.
It was a narcotics arrangement.
And he invested in
that, the first time.
And he got caught.
And it was obviously
a large sum.
To this day, he's been
in prison for 35 years.
So they took the same
money and used it
for a different purpose because
of the influence of the people
that was around them.
So we're all very much
affected by our environment.
And we all have choices who
we're going to associate with
and who we're not going
to associate with.
And it's very important in
our lives, on every level,
that we keep focused
on a higher principle.
Because if we're not focused
on that higher principle,
there are going to be so many
temptations and so many fears,
they're going to drag us down.
Us and them.
Spiritual platform--
when we're actually
connected to our
source, to our soul,
and we understand
our relationship
with the supreme
source, or with God,
then we see more in terms of we.
The more we empower each other,
the more we're empowered.
That's a higher vision.
The lower vision is, let
me push other people down
so I could go up.
Not far from here
is the Muir Woods.
How many of you have been there?
Please raise your hands.
Well, I live in Mumbai, so for
me it's really a distant place.
But every year, I go there and I
take a walk with my dear friend
and brother, [INAUDIBLE]
and we usually
try to find a very
secluded area where
we could just walk sit and
talk among the redwood trees.
One year, as we were
walking, we came
upon a large group of tourists.
And they were talking a
lot, so we want to just
walk by them really fast.
But as we were walking by,
we heard the forest ranger
who was in the middle
of that circle.
He said something that
really attracted my mind.
He said, I am going to tell
you the underground secret
of the redwood forest.
Now, I was a teenager in
the 1960s, and many of you
were there and many of
you heard about that era
of American history, and
we were really attracted
to underground secrets.
So I said, let's listen.
And he told a story.
He said, these trees
are the biggest, tallest
trees on earth-- the
Sequoia and redwoods.
Usually for a tree to grow
and sustain-- some hundred
of years old, some of them
are over a thousand years
old-- they have to
have really deep roots.
And there's really
no trees in the world
that have deep enough roots
to support what a redwood is.
The redwood trees
don't have deep roots.
And they're on
hilly terrain, which
makes them very vulnerable.
And it's lose soil.
And in this area there have
been devastating earthquakes
over the thousand years
that they've been standing.
There have been massive
blizzards, windstorms.
How do they keep growing?
And then he revealed
underground secret.
The roots of the redwood tree
underground, they grow outward.
Why?
They're specifically
growing, searching
for the roots of other trees.
And as soon as two roots
meet, they embrace.
They wrap around each other,
forming a permanent connection.
other.
They support each other.
Practically every
root is connected
to a root of another
tree all around them.
And in this way, every
tree in the entire forest
is directly or
indirectly connected,
supporting every other tree.
The unity is their strength.
And even little tiny redwoods
that are just coming out
of the ground are
very, very vulnerable,
but the roots of the
giant ancient trees
come and let them
wrap around them
and give them
their full support.
So in this world, we are
subjected to many storms.
Sometimes nice sunny days, also.
And there are
earthquakes in our lives,
individually, collectively,
on many levels.
There's that famous
saying, "United we stand,
divided we fall."
This is a beautiful
lesson of nature.
Any of our strength cannot
compare to unified strength.
Our own human body-- we
have so many more things
within the body.
Each organ is a different
shape, a different color,
and performs a completely
different function.
The lungs cannot do
what the heart does.
The brain cannot do
what the kidneys do.
The kidneys cannot
do what the knees do.
The pancreas cannot do
with the gall bladder does.
So they all have a very,
very special function.
And the stomach.
The stomach is
actually supplying food
to every other part of the body.
What if the stomach were to say,
you're all depending on me--
it's about me.
I'm going to keep
this food for myself.
I'm getting all these nutrients
and I'm getting all this food
and everybody wants it,
and everybody needs it,
but it's mine.
And yours depending
on me and I'm
going to keep it for myself.
What happens to the stomach?
And what happens all the
other parts of the body?
You see, a healthy human body
is when every part of the body
honors, respects, and
appreciates every other part.
And we recognize,
however big or small,
whatever color, whatever
shape, whatever function--
we're all part of a whole.
A healthy body, every
part is serving the whole.
And in serving
the whole, they're
serving every other part.
The health of a stomach is it
serves every part of the body.
The heart doesn't want to
keep the blood for itself.
The health of the heart
is supplying blood
to every part of the body.
The health of the
eye is not just
to try to see-- it's
to give direction
to every part of the body.
And when any part
of the body is not
in harmony with every
other part, it's disease.
It suffers, and
everything else suffers.
The same principle
as the redwood trees.
Seva, or service, is
the higher principle.
But the ego, which in
Sanskrit is ahamkar,
is always trying to
deceive us into thinking
it's about me, even at
the expense of others.
What is depression, and anxiety,
and incredible suffering
from stress and all
of these things?
it's actually the
core of those problems
on the level of the ego.
Because we're expecting so much,
and we're just not getting it.
But if we do get it, then
the nature of the ego
is to become arrogant and
condescending toward those
who don't get as much.
That ego is the root
of disease of so
many of the problems
in this world,
individually and collectively.
But it's so powerful.
How can we actually be
liberated from that?
The beginning is to
recognize that our real unity
and our real prosperity is
based on uniting in a higher
principle.
And it begins when we
ourselves, individually,
take the responsibility to
live according to those higher
principles.
In my own life, when
I was eight years old,
my mother told me,
she said, everyone
loves your father and
everyone loves me,
but we don't love
each other any more.
We're going to separate.
Now for an eight-year-old
boy-- and I never heard
of divorces in those days-- it
was just so confusing to me.
My mother and father
don't like each other,
and they're going to go
different directions?
I felt so disoriented.
I felt so bewildered.
I felt such pain in my heart.
I couldn't say a word.
I just sat there and cried.
And my mother looked at me and
didn't expect that reaction.
And then I jumped up and I ran
out the door of her bedroom
and I ran down the stairs
of our little house,
and I ran out the front door,
and I ran down my driveway,
and I ran across the street
and I ran across the block
and I went to a little forest.
And she couldn't find me.
When my father came home,
driving in his car--
at that time, when I
was eight, my father
was the largest car dealer of
a car called the Edsel in all
of Chicagoland.
And he didn't sell any of them.
It was one of the
biggest disasters
in automobile history.
He went bankrupt.
So he was struggling.
When he came home, I
listened with my ear
at the door of their
bedroom to hear
what they were going to speak.
My mother told my father
how I reacted to what
they had already decided.
There was complete silence.
And then I heard them both say,
for the sake of our children,
we are going to make this work.
It wasn't easy for them.
They had serious disagreements.
But somehow or other, they
found a higher principle
and they worked
through those things
that were impeding them
from embracing that higher
principle.
And incredibly,
in a few years, I
had never seen any two people
love each other as much
as them.
They were completely like
one heart in two bodies.
They really appreciated,
they really supported.
When my mother passed away,
they were married 58 years.
Real love is not just a romantic
attraction that comes and goes.
Real love is not
just a compatibility
that whatever I think
is what you think
and whatever you think is what I
think, and I expect this of you
and you expect this
of me, and if you
don't reach my
expectations then there's
something wrong with you.
Real love is based on a serious
commitment of responsibility
to a higher principle.
And then it's not just
a sensual, mental thing.
It really comes from the heart.
They were completely together
on a higher principle.
And I was just a little
eight-year-old boy,
and I was watching all this.
And you watch things
that affect you.
Things that are
very theoretical,
you see it and you forget it.
But when something
comes to your life, when
it's somewhat traumatic,
you really learn from it.
That's just the way human
nature sometimes is.
What was that principle?
It was like a foundation
to my own spiritual life.
I want to find that
higher principle.
Because as I grew
up, I was working
with people who were of
African American descent
while in high school,
and I saw how much they
were discriminated against.
They didn't have a
chance to really succeed
in the United States of
America in the 1950s and '60s.
Probably 95% really
didn't have that chance.
Constitutionally they
did, but socially, no.
So that same principle I
learned from my parents example
that there is a
higher principle.
I joined the Civil
Rights movement.
And I joined the counterculture
because the Vietnam War just
didn't make sense.
It didn't seem like a war
based on real ideals or values.
It seemed like a
war that was just
due to a lack of communication
between the two countries.
That's the way it
seemed to all of us.
It was either based on business
or lack of communication.
Is there really a purpose?
We didn't understand
if there was.
So those so many conflicts.
And that's when I
heard Gandhi say
you have to be the change
you want to see in the world.
And I understood if
I want to actually
be a part of the solution
rather than part of the problem,
I have to change myself.
And in my own, life it
put on a spiritual journey
to really find
harmony with myself.
The principle of yoga--
or for that matter,
according to literal definition,
religion, also-- is to reunite.
To bind back.
To create harmony between
our actions and our words,
with our hearts.
With our souls.
To harmonize the body, the
mind, with the living force.
And what is that living force?
In the Bible it is said,
what profitteth a person
if they gain the whole world but
they lose their immortal soul?
That's a universal principle.
In the Bhagavad Gita there's a
very, very profound definition
of that soul.
[SPEAKING SANSKRIT]
The soul is never born.
It never dies.
The soul by nature is
eternal, full of knowledge,
and full of joy.
And what is that joy?
It's the joy of love.
To love and to be loved.
And true love--
[SPEAKING SANSKRIT] --true love
is [SPEAKING SANSKRIT].
It's not selfish.
It's not arrogant.
It's based on true care.
And when you water
the root of the tree,
naturally that water extends
to every part of the tree--
the leaves, the
flowers, and the twigs.
So when we harmonize our
actions and our words,
our bodies and our minds, with
our own true self, the soul,
then naturally
from that point we
harmonize the soul
with the supreme soul,
or with God-- in my
tradition we call Krishna.
There are many names.
And when we harmonize ourselves
with the supreme source,
then like watering
the root of the tree,
we're harmonized with
everything and everyone.
There's a lot of environmental
problems in the world today.
And some people who've
really studied it carefully
say it's a severe crisis.
But it's not an
environmental crisis.
It's a crisis in human spirit.
When we're disconnected
from ourself,
when we're disconnected
from God, what happens?
We become disconnected
with other people.
And we start seeing
the differences.
And because of arrogance,
we're full of fear.
Were full of the
desire to exploit.
We have an obsessive need feel
ourselves superior to others.
Why?
That obsessive need to feel I
am better than other people is
because inside we're hollow.
We're shallow.
We're in poverty.
When I met Mother Theresa in
1971, she told that to me.
That the biggest
problem the world
is hunger not if the belly.
Give some food,
you can help that.
The heart.
She said, in my
travels, whether I'm
with the richest people
in London or New York
or Los Angeles or San
Francisco, or whether I'm
with poor little
villagers, people
have a hunger of the heart.
There's only one thing
they could satisfy
the hunger of the heart.
To love and to be loved.
And when we're disconnected
from that love, we're hungry.
And then we need so
much intoxication.
We need so much sex life.
We need so much various
forms of entertainment.
We need so much ways of just
forgetting that hollowness
that's within our heart.
But when we actually
discover who we are
and what we really
have, then we understand
through our business,
through our occupation,
through our
relationships, we're not
trying to grab something
to fill the void.
We have so much pleasure within.
Our greatest joy is to share it.
To share it through our wealth.
To share it through
our intelligence.
whatever influence
we have in this world.
To share it with our loved ones.
And ultimately, we see all
beings as our loved ones.
And we recognize that we
have a harmonious connection
with the environment as well.
If we're connected
to ourselves, then we
won't be thinking
in terms of greed.
Exploiting the environment
means endangering
every living being
on this planet
in a small way or a big way.
For me, that's not something
that a thoughtful, connected
person wants.
Because if we care about others,
we care about the environment.
We care about them.
Whether a person
is black or white
or red or yellow or
brown, or whether a person
is rich or poor, or
eastern or western,
or from one religion
or another religion,
or whether one is an elephant
or a cow or a dog or a cat.
Wherever there's life,
there's a sacred part of God.
And when we're connected
to our own self,
we feel the connection
of every living thing.
The Gita tells
[SPEAKING SANSKRIT].
This means that true
wisdom, true knowledge,
is not just about how much
data we store in our brain.
It's about being able
to see every living
being according to our inner
spiritual connection with them,
and therefore seeing
life as sacred.
And seeing the equality,
like the different parts
of the body, seeing themselves
in relation to the whole body,
not seeing themselves
separated from that.
And the Bible tells
the same thing.
It's the first and
great commandment,
to love God with all your
heart, all your mind, all
your strength, all your soul.
And what is the natural
consequence of such love?
That you love your
neighbor as yourself.
Everyone's our neighbor.
The trees, the air,
all the different kinds
of people and animals.
Everyone is our neighbor.
That disconnect is what makes
us instruments of conflict
ourselves, and so
vulnerable to falling
into the influence of
the conflicts that's
all over the place, and just
getting swept up, sucked in,
and just being a part of it.
When it is said, stand out
from among men and be separate,
it doesn't just mean becoming
a monk and leaving society.
It also means living
right within society.
But being in the world
but not of the world.
In other words, with
that strong connection,
with that foundation, with
our roots actually connected
to ourself and
connected to each other,
we learn that there is
no greater choice in life
than to live with
integrity and compassion.
That, to a cultured person,
integrity and compassion
is wealth.
The numbers in a bank account,
the amount of property
that are in our name, the amount
of nations we conquer-- that's
not wealth.
Because it doesn't bring
any happiness to the heart.
Things could give some
pleasure to the body and mind,
but cannot touch the heart.
Only love can touch the heart.
It is said that we should
love people and use
things to express our love.
Where does conflict come in?
When we love things
and use people
to get them and keep them.
And things means prestige.
Things means power.
Things means wealth of
all these different gross
and subtle material forms.
But what children
need to understand
is real wealthy is in our
integrity and our compassion.
Because those are principles
that are based on love.
Higher principles.
And when we make that
connection ourselves,
and when like-minded people
who are striving for that
embrace their roots with each
other through our affections,
then wonderful things
can happen in this world.
No one should ever
think that I'm
too small to make a huge
difference in the world.
Because the energy
of even one good deed
affects the entire planet
beyond what we can perceive.
There's a saying, you can tell
how rich you are by counting
how many things you have
that money cannot buy.
Now that doesn't
mean money is bad.
Money is really good
if good people have it.
But money is really bad
if bad people have it.
Similarly, power and fame.
If it's used with
compassion and integrity,
it can bring so much benefit
to ourselves and to others.
And that's where real joy is.
In our tradition, we
chant God's names.
We offer our
prayers in this way,
to be an instrument of
grace in whatever we do.
I know one person in
Mumbai-- he and his family
were among the largest
industrialist business
families in India.
And because of
change of policies,
because the government sometimes
changes policies that devastate
entire industries--
trading policies,
taxing policies,
labor policies--
that practically all
the people on his level
completely shut down.
And so many of them
were committing
suicide or depressed.
And he was coming to
our ashram every day,
and smiling and
dancing and singing.
And while he was struggling
like anything to work everything
out, all the lawsuits
and all tax issues
and all of the liquidations
that are necessary-- I mean,
it was incredible.
It was practically
all on his shoulders.
It was a huge
international corporation
he was trying to save.
So much pressure.
But while was doing it-- in
everything there's a risk.
He was helping feed
thousands and thousands
of people in the ghettos.
He was helping widows
and supporting them
for their whole lives.
He was helping the
monks, and somehow
or other empowering
them so that they
could go out and actually spread
beautiful, spiritual knowledge
to the world.
And I didn't know he
was doing any of it.
One day our accountant, he
came and said, you don't know
and nobody knows all
the wonderful things
he's doing to so many
people, because he doesn't
want to get any credit for it.
And he gave me a list of how
many thousands and thousands
of people he was actually
sustaining their lives
and infusing them with so much
spiritual inspiration as well.
And he made it through.
His companies,
they were changed,
but now they're very strong.
So what does it
mean to be detached?
It doesn't mean to just
walk away from things.
I asked him, how do you remain
so sweet and so kind and so
charitable, even when
you're struggling
more than practically
anybody else
could imagine, in the world
of politics and business
and everything, in labor?
He said, I'm just so grateful.
I'm so grateful that
I have God's names.
And I'm so grateful that
I have so many people who
encourage me and inspire me.
He's totally humble.
If you're grateful,
you're humble.
You can't be grateful
and arrogant.
They're contradictory.
If you're arrogant,
you can't really
be grateful for what you have.
You think you deserve it.
And when you think
you deserve it,
you're not really
grateful for it.
But people who have really
worked and achieved,
if they have this
higher conscious,
they're grateful
because they know--
just like when the stomach
provides really good nutrients
to the rest of the
body, the stomach isn't
saying you should surrender to
me to every part of the body.
The stomach understands
without all of you,
I can't do anything.
And ultimately, without the
grace of God, what can we do?
So conflict resolution
really has its deepest
and most sustainable
expression when
individually and
collectively we help
each other to really connect.
And give some time every day
to make that interconnection
through the people we're
with, through our spiritual
practices, and to the integrity
and character in which we live.
These are some of my thoughts.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Would anyone like to
ask any questions?
How was the experience
starting a hospital in Mumbai?
It was a wonderful experience.
What happened?
It's the same redwood principle.
I was giving talks like this in
the colleges and universities
of Mumbai.
I was invited.
And many of them were
medical colleges.
So many young people who
are in medical college,
they really wanted
to dedicate what
they do for that
higher principle-- it's
called bhakti-- of loving
service to the Supreme,
to God, who we call
Krishna, and to humanity,
who are all children of God.
So they really believed in
that, and ultimately they
were all
undergraduates, and then
they graduated from
medical school,
and then they went on
to become specialists
and super-specialists.
And after some time, within
our little congregation,
we had gynecologists,
and ENT specialists,
and cancer surgeons,
and orthopedic surgeons,
and radiologists, and
general practitioners,
and we had pathologists
and everyone else.
And we had ayurvedic doctors,
and homeopathic doctors,
and naturopathic doctors.
They all went to
different schools
and they all had their
different practices.
And one day we just--
I don't have any money.
I don't have anything.
But I'm like a
little cheerleader
who likes to encourage the
people who are doing stuff.
I said, why don't we just
start our own hospital
and we'll all work together?
So everyone was really enthused.
And because within
our congregation,
people in business and
industry and everything
like that, they were really
inspired by the idea,
so they helped-- they
provided the funds,
and we built a hospital.
And then we had all
our doctors and all
of our nurses and
other people who
wanted to be a part of this, a
spiritually oriented hospital.
There was a family that
had a chain of vegetarian
restaurants.
And the father left the
restaurants to his children,
and he said, let me run all the
cooking for the canteen and all
the patients of hospital.
So he took charge the kitchen.
And although they're getting
paid and everything like that,
but that's not really
why they're doing it.
That's a detail.
They're really doing
it because they just
love to work together
for a higher principle.
And it's actually
quite beautiful.
Medicine is a lot like religion.
There's a lot a fundamentalism.
If you talk to some
ayurvedic doctors-- not all,
but the really extreme
ones-- allopathic medicine
is like a nuclear poison.
It's destroying the world.
And there's certain really
extreme allopathic doctors
who consider ayurvedic
to just be witchcraft
and superstition and
misleading people.
And naturopath and ayurveda,
they have so many differences,
and homeopath-- everybody
has so many differences.
But in my non-medical
experience,
I've seen that every
single one of them
heals people in their own ways.
So why not work together?
So we have all the main
branches of allopathy,
plus we have a wing with
ayurveda, homeopathy,
naturopathy, acupuncture.
And everyone works together, and
it's actually quite incredible.
And we have a spiritual
care department
because, just like
recently, our devotees
is from this hospital went to
Nepal after the earthquake.
And they were telling me after,
they were helping people.
The people had broken
arms and broken necks
and our surgeons were fixing
them and putting casts on them
and giving them
whatever they required.
But the thing that the
people appreciated the most
was not just fixing their limbs.
Because almost all of them,
they lost family members.
They lost their homes.
They lost their businesses.
Emotionally, they
were destitute.
You fix their arm, you don't
make their life all that much
better.
It was the spiritual care--
giving them the encouragement,
giving them hope, helping
them with their lives
in the spirit of compassion--
that they really appreciated,
more than anything.
When people are sick, when
people are dying-- and a third
of the patients
of the hospitals,
almost half actually, are
Muslims, Christians, Parsis,
Sikhs, Jains, sometimes Jews,
and about half are Hindus.
And the spiritual care,
everyone is equally enlivened,
because it's based on universal
spiritual principles that
uplift the heart, uplift
the souls, and give us hope.
Even if we have to die
to understand and connect
to who we really are
and who we really--
our real connections with each
other beyond birth and death.
So it started real
small, and now it's
doing a lot of
wonderful service.
And the more they actually
reach out to help,
for the pleasure of
Krishna, the more
they really reach out
to help the society,
the happier and more
enthusiastic they are.
I'll give one example.
We have a cataract eye camp in
a place called Barsana, which
is a holy place where Sri
Radha and Krishna lived
5,000 years ago.
And so many pilgrims go there
from all over the world.
But outside of
Barsana, that there
are villages that
are so poor, people
have never gone to
school in their life.
They've never seen a
dentist in their life.
And if they don't
get a free surgery,
they're going to go
blind from cataracts.
So we do about a
thousand surgeries
in the span of about two
weeks when we go there.
And we treat about
three thousand.
And one volunteer
doctor, who wasn't even
part of Bhaktivedanta
Hospital, he's
just quite a
materialistic personality,
but he just was convinced to go.
And he left his very
luxurious home in Bombay
because doctors can make a lot.
And Barsana, there's no
luxurious facilities.
People are living in tents,
and it's cold, and it's muddy,
and it's really
primitive, actually.
And he was living
in those conditions.
And he was doing
surgeries because he just
felt, let me do something.
And there was one old
lady, she was about 90,
and she was going blind in
both eyes with cataracts.
And he operated on her.
This lady was so poor.
She was just dressed in rags.
She had nothing materially.
She had a lot of love for God.
For Radha.
When he took the
bandage off of her eyes,
and it was the
first time she could
see clearly in the years--
very uneducated lady,
and very, what to
say, unsophisticated--
she was so happy.
With her hand, as hard as she,
could she started slapping
the doctor, this wealthy
doctor from Bombay--
she started slapping
him on top of the head.
And she said, I bless you
my child, I bless you.
I bless you.
I can see again.
I can see from Krishna.
I bless you.
I bless you, I bless you.
May Radha shower
her mercy on you.
And she was saying like
that, and she was crying,
and joy and blessing him.
And some of our people saw
she was really hitting him.
He started crying.
He said, I've never
experienced such
a deep, meaningful
experience in my life.
I did something for this lady.
And that was about
eight years ago.
Every year he comes and
brings his whole family.
And it's a loss, because in
the two weeks that he comes,
that means two weeks he's
not making money in Mumbai.
And his children, during
their school vacation,
he brings them there
to just help do
seva for these poor people.
Because he wants to share
this wealth with them too.
What is wealth?
Wealth is what really
improves the quality
and the love of our lives.
And in whatever profession
we're in, that's the principle.
And our Bhaktivedanta Hospital,
in our spiritual care,
we try to help people
understand that.
Because when they do,
they could actually
process whatever
difficulties they're
going in with gratitude
rather than bewilderment.
With affection
rather than anger.
Because they're connected
to God and each other.
I hope that answers
your question.
Is there any other questions?
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
RADHANATH SWAMI: Well, there's
different kinds of meditation.
You could chant God's
names while you're
running the marathon, and
that's also meditation.
Actually, I'm not
a marathon runner
but I walk sometimes fast,
and that's a meditation too.
We chant this Maha Mantra,
so with inhalation I
just remember a name of
God, and with exhalation I
remember the mantra.
Hare Krishna, Hare Krishna.
And that's actually meditation.
And it's actually as deep and
as effect a the meditation as
sitting like this, because
it's not whether you're
doing this or running.
It's a matter of how
you're connecting
and how you're absorbing.
So by chanting your beautiful
mantra when you're sitting,
that's beautiful.
But even when you're running,
or even when you're walking,
or even when you're sitting .
So there's different ways and
they'll have the same result
if we're sincere.
But that connection, if
we value that connection,
is something very important.
The body, the mind,
the soul, and God,
when we value that
connection and really want
to be an instrument of grace,
then we're really connected.
I'm truly grateful to
each and every one of you
for being here today and
allowing me to be here.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]